[Music]
many people would dream of having an old
Porsche 911 in their garage Friedhelm
vallah felt bought his Porsche 11 years
ago looking for the car wasn't easy and
now getting it into his own garage and
out again is difficult too he uses
planks of wood and a clever trick to
drive out carefully
[Music]
the garage flipped home says the garage
is so low and there is an angle from the
curbside so he cannot drive in straight
on so he has to approach from the side
to get the car into the garage links
exit in the garage affront so good once
he has taken the beast out of its cage
it is time to show what it is capable of
fleet helm loves taking the 3.2 liter
Carrera
out of forest spin in the Eifel region
he decided to buy a Porsche in 2006 it
took him six months to track down his
dream car
[Music]
Friedhelm says he had a mental image of
the car he was looking for a certain car
and when he saw this one he decided to
buy it after all the necessary repairs
to the electrical system replacing the
top and giving the Porsche a thorough
cleaning he ended up with the car we are
driving right now Alden the 68 year old
has put a lot of hard work into the car
and that makes for a special close bond
between the owner and the vehicle which
was built in 1984 time has taken its
toll and now freed Helm's friend
taillight lens a hand with repairs he's
also a vintage car fan and owns several
of them the two men enjoyed tinkering
with the cars and teos garage and
talking shop as they go about their
chores problems are inevitable as free
tom explains
[Music]
he says that when he was assembling the
car he didn't install the door properly
and when it got really damp recently the
inner paneling buckles it turned out he
had overlooked up fastening when he was
preparing it now the interior paneling
has to be removed
I'm the first human in timbal I should
bethey in happy nothing was the conflict
in for climb gets up about we hadn't it
is all part and parcel of owning a
classic you always have some work to do
on it
but it can't be fun
husband father in following the car
still has the original engine and
transmission but a die-hard Porsche fan
will be able to spot some changes to the
body
[Music]
the both Atomics plays that the car has
a replacement rear spoiler front spoiler
and hood wouldn't fill eyes this
interior isn't original either and that
makes it really special in most ATO good
involve mr. dim by Porsche established
that it belonged to a special 1987 model
with very Porsches name on the headrest
the nam-seok from ferry posture of their
cough streets the alterations were
carried out in Italy by a previous owner
back then Porsche tried to track down
the special model there but the search
was in vain the roof opens automatically
but Friedhelm still has to help to make
sure it folds properly
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
driving with the top down makes the
color even more fun and fleet hump says
what would be better than taking to the
open road and a Porsche Carrera
[Applause]
[Music]